a lot of people are worried about how to
Stave off imminent catastrophic man-made
climate change well
Spanish climate Minister Teresa Ribera
has just showed the whole world how
Minister ministress Ribera recently
attended a climate change Summit hosted
by the European Union and she showed up
to the summit riding a bicycle and she
rode that bicycle for approximately 100
yards surrounded by emitting security
vehicles after she got out of a
limousine which she had entered after
stepping off a private jet
our own transportations are Pete bootage
pulled a similar stunt a couple years
ago sometime when he was not taking
maternity leave mayor Pete pulled up to
a cabinet meeting riding a bicycle
which a hidden camera caught him
unloading from the back of an armored
SUV just a few blocks off his
destination my favorite part of these
performances is that they actually
marginally increase pollution into the
air because the vehicles need to idle
while mayor Pete and the Spanish lady
prepare their bicycle rides but they are
worthwhile demonstrations nonetheless
because they show us a great example of
what we should sacrifice to the nature
gods
and it's precisely what they are
sacrificing to the nature gods and that
is precisely nothing I'm Michael Knowles
this the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show this episode is
brought to you by good ranchers get
great need at a secure price and 30
bucks off your order with code nulls go
to goodranchors.com use code Knowles
today
Senator tuberville has stepped in it boy
he's in trouble for some comment about
white nationalism or some nonsense we'll
get into whatever CNN is crying about in
just a moment first though speaking of
foreign performers
Mr zielinski over there in Ukraine is
furious that NATO led by the United
States is not going to immediately enter
into World War III zielinski
is angry because while Joe Biden and the
West broadly has said that Ukraine can
eventually join NATO
Biden has said that Ukraine cannot join
NATO right now because if Ukraine joined
NATO right now well it's still engaged
in a war with Russia that would
instantly trigger Article 5 that would
instantly trigger a world war with a
nuclear former superpower something that
the U.S managed to avoid for the
entirety of the Cold War but this punk
in Ukraine wants to start it up right
now what is uh Mr zielinski say he says
it's unprecedented and absurd when time
frame is not set neither for the
invitation nor for Ukraine's membership
it seems there is no Readiness or
neither to invite Ukraine to Nato nor to
make it member of the alliance this
means that a window of opportunity is
being left to bargain Ukraine's
membership in nato in negotiations with
Russia and for Russia this means
motivation to continue its Terror
uncertainty is weakness and I will
openly discuss this at The Summit
it's my best it's not quite my fouchy
impression but it's the best I can do
for zielinski and
in a way look I don't particularly care
Vera zielinski I don't care for U.S
foreign policy which has dragged this
war on needlessly I don't care for the
protestations of the liberal
establishment which for decades now has
been provoking Russia into some kind of
a war which has ignored the warnings A
very wise even sometimes liberal
Statesmen like George Kennan like Sam
Nunn like Daniel Patrick Moynihan like
lots of like Henry Kissinger actually
like lots of wise American foreign
policy Specialists who've said hey if
you guys in NATO aggress into Ukraine
that's going to destroy Ukraine's status
as a buffer State between great powers
and it's going to provoke Russia to war
especially because NATO has been
aggressive in the past and invaded
countries in the past Russia is going to
view that as an unacceptable security
threat add on to that Joe Biden
literally invited Russia to invade part
of Ukraine and said that if it were only
a minor incursion he wouldn't do very
much about it never mind that zelinski
has blamed Joe Biden for getting rid of
the sanctions on Russia which also
invited more Russian aggression never
mind all of that
zielinski has a little bit of a right to
be irritated here
he does I don't I don't like him that
much I don't like that he's trying to
provoke World War III I think Joe Biden
actually made the right call here to put
the brakes on Ukraine membership in NATO
I don't think Ukraine should join NATO I
don't think Ukraine should joined the
European Union but zielinski has a
little bit of a right to be irritated
because the U.S and the West broadly
has been
encouraging Ukraine to make more and
more overtures toward the west
the U.S backed a color revolution in
Ukraine in 2014 the maidan revolution
which got rid of a pro-russian leader
and installed more pro-western leaders
in Ukraine
head of the CIA landed in Kiev two weeks
after that Revolution there's a little
on the nose guys and and so they've been
dangling all of this wonderful Western
privilege in front of Ukraine Ukraine
gravitates toward that privilege
now all of a sudden we say no actually
hold on you can't join no actually
we're going to give you Munitions we're
going to give you weapons
but we're not going to decisively end
this war right now and so Ukraine's
caught between a rock and a hard place
and and Ukraine is getting absolutely
pummeled right now and and they seem to
be in a pretty brutal position
is the West has no interest in this war
winding down anytime soon the West
benefits from this war the West gets to
turn Europe away from Russian energy
back toward American Energy the West
gets to strengthen the NATO alliance if
for no reason out of existential fear
and Russia benefits from prolonging this
war they're losing a lot of troops but
Russia also gets to gain more territory
in Ukraine it's hard to see how Russia
could possibly lose the territory that's
conquered in Ukraine at this point so
the only people who lose are Ukraine I
get why is zelinski is irritated by this
but this is why it was a a really
foolish strategy
for Ukraine to give up its status as a
buffer State buffer states are good
buffer states have worked for all of
human history when you're caught between
two big Powers it behooves you not to
pick sides it behaves you to play them
off against one another and get the best
benefits you possibly can from both but
because we don't study history anymore
because of Fallen human nature we just
keep repeating the same errors of the
past in this case potentially with
disastrous consequences if Solinski gets
his way with the consequence of World
War III so when things get a little
crazy in the political order you're
going to want to check out Birch gold
right now text Knowles to 98 98 98 as
central banks in countries such as China
India and Australia begin looking to
transition to a digital currency the
Federal Reserve has been contemplating
the same for the U.S with a digital
currency the government could track
every single purchase you make officials
could even prohibit you from purchasing
certain products or easily freeze or
sees part or all of your money Times
Like These are a great reminder to
diversify a portion of your savings into
gold and you can do that with the help
of Birch gold Birch gold is where I get
my gold so do thousands of other
concerned Savers Birch gold will help
you convert an existing Ira or 401K into
an IRA in Gold you don't pay a penny out
of pocket when currencies fail gold is a
safe haven how much more time does the
Dollar have protect your savings with
gold Birch gold has an eight plus rating
with the Better Business Bureau
thousands of happy customers text
Knowles kwles to 98 98 98 get your free
info kit on gold if a central bank
digital currency becomes a reality it
will be nice to have a little bit of
gold to depend on text Knowles kwles to
98 98 98
speaking of places known for their bio
labs
you see what I did there you catch that
the scientists behind a paper
discrediting
discrediting the lab leak hypothesis
around covid-19 have apparently admitted
that they were pretty much just willing
to push a lie in order to keep public
opinion from turning against China we
found this out because of Congressional
hearings this was just broadcast on
C-Span
we've got a co-author of the March 2020
nature medicine article the proximal
origin of SARS cov2 covid the wuflu the
China virus and other scientists who
collaborated on the paper
openly worrying saying goodness gracious
if if this paper shows that that kovid
started in China well then it's going to
be a complete mess and they're going to
be all sorts of political ramifications
so we've got to discourage people from
observing the obvious fact that this
virus began at of a lab leak not in
nature but out of a lab leak in China
here are the texts
one of your colleagues who's not here
today was invited Dr rambutt he said I
don't know if I should say this in
committee room or not but given the
blank show that this would happen if
anyone serious seriously accused the
Chinese of even accidental release my
feeling is we should say that given
there is no evidence of a specifically
engineered virus we cannot possibly
distinguish between Natural Evolution
and Escape so we are content with
ascribing it to natural processes his
concern was would he piss off China
that's what his concern was
um so look something happened here
politicians May flip-flop
scientists do not flip-flop in a matter
of 72 hours
but the scientists do flip-flop if the
scientists are politicians and these
scientists were always politicians
because they work in public health
and you know I hate to say I told you so
some of us were saying this from the
beginning of covid when Dr fauci came
out there and he said listen I don't
have any public political opinions I'm a
scientist I'm the science I'm the vicar
of science on Earth
uh when he said that he ignored half of
his job which is the public part and
public just means politics so they were
always politicians this the job of a
public scientist to take into account
politics when they demur and they say no
no I I hate it when we have to play
politics well then you hate your job
because your job is to do that and so
this was a really great stuff from this
Congress lady
and really bad stuff from the public
health scientists because they were
saying we are going to lie we know that
political ramifications would be bad for
the liberal establishment so we're gonna
lie and say that we can't really
distinguish between the natural virus
and a a human prodded and poked and
strengthened virus that leaks out of a
laboratory out of a strong bio lab in
Wuhan so we're just going to lie and say
we can't tell and we're going to lie and
say that this is probably natural and
that's what they did
so what do we conclude from this do we
conclude that fauci's going to face any
consequences he won't
do we conclude that Francis Collins and
IH is going to face any consequences he
won't
do we conclude that any of these
scientists who sent these messages will
face God they won't nothing will happen
they got it they got it we figured out
we figured out
in the early 1990s that LBJ stole a
senate election in 1948 in Texas and we
found it out in Robert Carro the top
biographer of LBJ did a great job
proving this
a lot of good at dentists doesn't matter
no one will be held to consequences LBJ
was dead at that point
it's good to be Vindicated long after
the fact but not because you're going to
hold the Bad actors responsible for what
they did in the past it's so that we can
look to the Future and not be fooled
again because I promise you the next
time the libs try to pull a stunt like
this you're going to hear all the same
nonsense from not just the establishment
media not just the hack politicians and
not just the really fancy people at the
universities you're going to hear it
from the so-called scientists too and
they're going to say oh no no listen the
science is very clear and all you rude
deplorable idiots you don't know
anything about the sign so listen to us
you should not listen to us they don't
have any credibility they are liars they
are admitted Liars
the only lesson to take away here is is
not that you should be fighting
yesterday's battle and trying to lock up
fauci do your best please I'd I'd love
it if the guy faced consequences I just
think practically potentially it's not
going to happen so you can't be Fooled
Again
and all of these questions on the
ideologies that are permeating our
culture that we're not allowed to talk
about on big Tech that would be a good
example of the scientists obviously
being wrong on the uh other questions
surrounding the efficacy of vaccines
forget about the virus for a second but
the vaccines that'd be a good example of
of the experts and Geniuses being wrong
maybe even in more political matters
when we're told that our elections are
totally 100 secure do you really believe
those guys I don't really believe those
guys I see a lot of evidence to the
contrary
the more that our established
authorities are caught openly admitting
not just they made mistakes but that
they are liars that they're
intentionally deceiving you
the less credibility they have and the
more you're going to have to rely on
your gut today in the year of Our Lord
2023 in the United States your gut has a
much better track record of honesty and
integrity than any of these established
public genius scientific authorities and
so the reasonable rational choice
is to trust a hunch a gut instinct
rather than to trust these Liars
speaking of dubious science
and ideologies that we're not allowed to
talk about on a certain big Tech video
platform
we have been told by the fancy people
by the responsible people by the people
in the suits and the ties That doctors
are not performing
[Music]
strong
now speaking of bags of meat when you
want to get really good bags of meat to
feed your body you got to check out good
ranchers it's the best transition I've
ever had in this entire show right now
head on over to goodranchers.com use
promo code Knowles if you have not heard
yet the FDA approved lab-grown chicken
for sale yes meat formed in a lab will
soon be coming to a store near you yuck
if you prefer meat grown in a pasture
instead of a petri dish then you need
good ranchers not only do they sell real
meat from real animals but they sell the
best meat this country has to offer from
Steakhouse quality cuts of beef to
better than organic chicken everything
good Rancher sources is from local farms
in America plus right now you'll get 30
bucks off with my code Knowles
goodranchers.com they've got terrific
products absolutely top tier stuff I had
their burgers the other night I almost
died they're so freaking good also you
can't call the scientists and lab to ask
about their fake meat but good ranchers
has a team of people available for you
to call and answer all your questions
real meat real service what are you
waiting for enjoy real meat real service
today with Ranchers go to ranchers.com
use code Knowles for 30 bucks off any
box promo code Knowles at
goodranters.com goodranchors.com
American Meat delivered the greatest
interview show on YouTube according to
many people many people are saying it
yes or no is back with an all new
episode discussing the most talked about
movie in America sound of Freedom movie
star Jim Caviezel American hero Tim
Ballard join me for tough questions and
stiff drinks a stiff drink that Jim
Caviezel took from me actually check out
this teaser it's just a coincidence that
many Elites in Hollywood and big Tech
are also some of the harshest critics of
the sound of Freedom movie this is
Michael think it's a coincidence
thinking about it for a second
[Laughter]
don't give me the answer
it's cheating it's cheating
this is your last chance for the yes or
no game discount rather than giving Jeff
Bezos more money on Prime day give it to
Jeremy instead get five bucks off when
you order yes or no go to dailywear.com
shop getyourgame today daily wire.com
shop get five bucks off your order of
the yes or no game do not wait at the
last chance to get five bucks off is
today
stories winding its way through the
courts it's going to make it up to the
Supreme Court certainly and
it's a story that divides the right a
little bit
but but gets a lot deeper at the heart
of one of the big issues in our country
education than some of the recent laws
have been passed and
this case is not about whether you
in this case is not about whether you
can have gay porn in elementary schools
it's it's a little trickier than that
the case is about
whether or not a Catholic School can
fire a teacher for being openly
homosexual
you've got two rights supposed rights in
America pitted right up against one
another the right to religious liberty
and the right
to have special civil rights protections
on the basis of sexual orientation and
gender identity which is a very recently
codified civil rights protection that
comes from the Supreme Court in cases
like the Bostock case the Harris Funeral
Home case it's a rewriting of the civil
rights law and the civil rights law was
rewriting of the Constitution but but
that's the law of the land right now so
what is it because you can't
simultaneously have both does the
Catholic School have the right to teach
Catholic stuff with Catholic teachers or
do homosexuals have the right to have
any job they want open homosexuals
which is
Lonnie Billard
announced on Facebook that he was
engaged to his partner of 14 years
so they were going to have a same-sex
marriage and he wrote on Facebook he
said if you don't agree with this keep
it to yourself and he was not even a
full-time teacher he was a substitute
teacher at this Catholic School
Charlotte Catholic High School and then
he found out that school wasn't wasn't
picking him up anymore
because he's an open homosexual
in the U.S court of appeals for the
fourth circuit Richmond is an early test
right now of whether or not
the first amendment protects a
business's right
this case a Catholic school's right to
to not employ
people who violate their moral code
this is a really crucial case and I I
know that people are going to be more
sympathetic to the substitute teacher
because they're going to say look we all
have gay friends and cousins and stuff
one of some of my very best teachers
that I had in school were openly gay it
was a little bit of a different time
back then when being openly gay didn't
mean you were marching down the street
in New York City saying
you didn't have gay porn in elementary
schools a little bit of a different time
but people are going to be much more
sympathetic to the teacher here and yet
the only choice
the only choice if we're going to have
religion in America at all is to side
with the Catholic School
if a religious school does not have the
right to uphold its religious principles
in education
then religious education is banned in
America
effectively
education is about
forming minds and raising up young
people
and religious education has a I'm not
going to say distinctly moral component
to it because all education has a moral
component whether we want to admit it or
not liberal Schools public schools they
have a moral component they
rigorously instill a moral view in their
students on environmentalism on the
sexual Revolution on all the rest of it
on diversity on everything there's just
a little subtler about it
but
if this the school
the religious school does not have the
right to hire teachers who uphold
the educational vision of the school
and to not hire teachers or to fire
teachers who openly oppose the entire
educational vision of the school or a
key component of it
then that means that religious education
is illegal
but because nature aborts a vacuum
it doesn't mean that now education is
going to be neutral as the Liberals
pretend
it just means that only one religious
view actually an anti-religious view is
going to be enshrined in schools it
means that schools
not only will not have the right to
teach the Christian view of sex
or the Jewish group of sex or the Muslim
view of sex or any kind of traditional
view of sex it doesn't just mean that
you don't have the right to that
it doesn't even just mean that you do
have the right to teach a more liberal
view of sex
it means that you must teach a more
liberal view of sex
means you have to that's the law
because if you don't the state will come
after you
so that's going to be a big test and
this is it's far from Clear what the
Supreme Court's going to do the Supreme
Court despite our allegedly 6-3
conservative Court
sided with
it's in Bostock sided with
and the idea of a civil right for sexual
orientation gender identity
in
the Harris Funeral Homes case
so if I had to place bets right now
I fear there's a good chance that
Catholic Education just it effectively
becomes outlawed in America now the
Court's been pretty good about religious
liberty cases the kind of as an okay
record so maybe there's a chance there
I would say call call your Congressman I
would I would say make this very clear
that you you don't want religious
education to be completely abolished in
America by nine lawyers on the Supreme
Court speaking of weird sex stuff
there's a story I meant to get to not a
long one but the story about a Newport
Beach couple
uh young guy good looking couple young
as a surgeon and his wife and they're
apparently swingers and they got in
trouble because they went to a bar and
they picked up these women and then
brought them back to their place and the
women say that they kind of came too the
women think that they were drugged and
that these this couple this young
surgeon and his wife were actually
preying on them
and and we're drugging them to get
involved into all sorts of weird stuff
back at their place and so when the
women came to they said we got to get
out of here whatever and they left and
they they go after them well the charges
were just dropped against the Newport
Beach surgeon and his girlfriend
and the question in the case is
were they swingers or predators in fact
that's this article here on Yahoo News
asks that very question were they
swingers or were they Predators was it
just fun kind of consensual gallivanting
or was there something dark and
nefarious here
and my question is what's the difference
what's the difference really
they're I'm not saying there's no
distinction whatsoever between the two
cases but in both cases they're
predators in both cases this Newport
Beach couple is not going out to will
the good of these other women and to
edify them and build them up and care
for them and take care of their needs
and get married to them or anything like
that they're just going out to satisfy
their own base appetites and to use
women in the process and maybe they
cross the line even further and drugged
these women in or in some other way kind
of coerced them but maybe they just
merely seduced them in a bar and took
them back and used their bodies and then
threw them out on the street
either way though that's predatory
behavior
in fact the old ancient Greeks go to all
Uncle Plato talked about this too and
said that
uh rape physical rape is in fact less
severe than seduction today in our
modern society we think that's crazy
what are you talking about seduction
that's just that's consensual but rape
you know that's one of the worst crimes
yeah rape is one of the worst crimes but
the reason that our old ancient Greek
buddies thought that is because
a physical rape is just a violation of
the body a seduction is a violation not
only of the body but also the intellect
and of the Soul it pierces much much
deeper that's the kind of behavior that
they're engaging in it's a kind of
behavior that's totally enshrined in our
society and it's enshrined in feminism
and it's enshrined in the sexual
Revolution and it's an idea that that as
long as you can get someone to meekly
mutter yes that you have the right to do
whatever you want to satisfy your own
base desires it's an idea of pure
selfishness and it's an idea of
predation and predatory behavior the
swingers are predators what's the
difference speaking of
Newport Beach places known for
fundraising
our friend Vivek ramaswamy not a swinger
to my knowledge I'm not don't draw the
wrong conclusion from that transition I
was transitioning onto political
fundraising nothing to do with the weird
Newport Beach couple uh the vague
Vivek has a very novel idea for how to
raise money for his presidential
campaign
here it is
this campaign is founded on the truth
here's the truth of how political
fundraising actually works
there's a tiny group it's an oligopoly
of people who raise money bundling and
otherwise who get to keep a large
percentage sometimes up to ten percent
of what they actually raise
that doesn't make any sense to belong to
a small group of people I don't like
this system as it exists but if that's
the system we're going to have my view
is let's democratize that and make it
possible for everybody to make money as
well so if you're supporting me and
you're part of this movement and you
want to help us actually raise that
money
join my kitchen cabinet new program
we're launching where you help me raise
the money you get a unique link to do it
we'll have a special relationship I'm
going to keep giving you phone calls
telling you how I think you can be most
effective for us but the money you raise
you get to keep 10 percent of it
I love it I think it's a great idea he's
right
in that there is a class of people
called political fundraisers and they
work for these campaigns and they raise
a boatload of money and they get to keep
a decent chunk of it themselves as their
job
so he's saying why are we doing this why
are we creating this professional class
of political Consultants politics is
supposed to be about you it's supposed
to be about ordinary citizens and
personal connections so I'm going to
increase that personal connection to you
and I'm going to incentivize you don't
we support Market incentives here on the
right yeah I think we do don't we do
that in America yeah I think we do so
we're going to incentivize you to raise
some money some people are
disingenuously calling this a pyramid
scheme this is not a pyramid scheme at
all a pyramid scheme is where you
you sell some stupid product and then
you you convince other people not only
to buy your product but to sell that
product for you and then you get a cut
of of what that person sells and then
they do it and they do it and they do it
it keeps going on and on and on and the
idea is you build up this kind of funnel
into a pyramid
it's not any anything even close to what
vague is saying he's just saying hey if
you raise some money for me you get 10
percent
that's it
no pyramid no multi-layer no you just
whatever you raise you get 10 I think
this is a great idea and the best part
of this
it's not that he's raising money Vivek
doesn't need money he's a very wealthy
man it's not that
uh I don't know that people are going to
make a ton of money people might make
some money but they're not going to make
an insane amount of money on this the
best part of it is that he's trying
something new he's shaking up the race
in his campaign promises and the way
he's conducting the race and even in the
way he's conducting the operations of
the campaign even not not just the way
he's conducting social media ads but the
way he's conducting fundraising he's
he's coming to this race with the out of
the box vision of an entrepreneur which
is what he is and this is why he keeps
jumping up the ranks in this race Vivek
right now nationally is in third place
and the this is the the biggest positive
probably about vivek's presidential
campaign and it's so shocking that this
guy who pretty much nobody had heard of
six months ago is now the number three
guy in the GOP race for president and
it's the biggest knock on the number two
guy in the race Ron DeSantis who's got
so many great things going for him he's
a very impressive person he's very
intelligent he's done a great job in
Florida he would probably make a great
president but his campaign is stuck in
the Rut for precisely this reason all
Vivek is doing is just trying new stuff
shaking things up during speaking at the
wall and all the DeSantis campaign seems
to be doing is doubling down on a
strategy that is slowly losing them
support and if they don't turn it around
it's going to seriously hamper their
chances if not totally foreclose their
chances of making it to the nomination
you know there are a lot of unhappy
people out there
most of them think if I could just get
the right job if I could just
find the right spouse if I can just have
a little bit more money then everything
would be all right just this one little
change well the truth is happiness is
something you can achieve without adding
anything else to your life and in fact
perhaps you must but don't take my word
for it take the founder of prayer use
word for it Dennis Prager and a brand
new episode of prageru's Masters program
streaming exclusively on daily wire plus
Dennis will show you how you can be
happy right now and prageru's master's
program Dennis is sharing 40 years worth
of hard-earned wisdom that explores all
sorts of topics such as the differences
between men and women the consequences
of secularism and the case for marriage
in this week's episode Dennis will show
you how to overcome the hurdles to
happiness I can guarantee at least one
of those hurdles you've never considered
before you will not want to miss this
episode go to dailywireplus.com
become a member watch prageru's master's
program today
my favorite comment yesterday is from
stetenwalters574 not to be confused with
the 573 other Stanton Walters is on
YouTube who says don't forget basic math
that's another tool of the far right
that's true
the aspects of the far right that you've
really got to look out for exercising
being on time working hard
speaking English
basic math literacy I don't know um
be not screaming all the time being sort
of
quiet normal that but there are lots of
warning signs of being on the far right
speaking at the far right
the GOP nomination for president Vivek
is now in third place according to a
morning consult survey
now I don't want to overstate what third
place means Trump is running away with
this nomination Trump is at 56 percent
he according to morning consult is 30
points up on his next closest rival
Rhonda Santa 17 and Rhonda Santos is way
up on Vivek Rama Swami is up nine
percent so a little over
100 percent more support than vivekas
right now
but
it's pretty good man I don't know that's
pretty impressive Rhonda Santos is one
of the most impressive Republican
politicians in the country frankly in my
lifetime and this guy Vivek is just
coming up and he's not all that far away
I guess in terms of raw numbers and
Vivek is one point above the former Vice
President of the United States Mike
Pence who was a popular governor of
Indiana who is a popular Congressman
this guy's a fake point up on him
he's almost triple on Nikki Haley almost
triple on Tim Scott almost triple on
Chris Christie so much for the
chrysosons he is way above Hutchinson is
at one percent poor burgum who's running
is a socially liberal
cut taxes kind of candidate he's at zero
percent Suarez zero percent heard zero
percent
I I've I've been making this warning and
I've been a little tough on DeSantis the
past few days and I'm tough on DeSantis
out of love because I really personally
like the guy and I like a lot of the
people associated with his campaign
keep this up and you're going to lose
simple as that what the DeSantis
campaign is betting on right now
is that they're going to hold firm at I
don't know I don't know what they're
going to hold for a minute we're going
to hold firm at 22 now it's at 17 it
keeps dropping but they're going to hold
firms somewhere until the first debate
and the first debate is going to be
where Rhonda Santos really makes his
Mark against Trump and maybe he will
maybe he won't
Trump has great debates and Trump has
pretty bad debates so that's a that's a
coin flip you don't know how to draw and
I bet if recent performance is any
indication
Trump's looking pretty good at his
debate skills at his stage skills it
looks like he's kind of got some of his
mojo back but furthermore if if the
DeSantis campaign thinks that that's
going to be the race because everyone's
going to be piling on Trump and that's
where DeSantis is going to really deal
The Knockout blow and that's when his
numbers are going to switch well I think
he got another thing coming because all
the guns are not going to be trained on
trumpet that first debate the guns are
going to be trained on Ron DeSantis
because Ron DeSantis campaign is showing
blood in the water right now Rhonda
santis is 39 points below Donald Trump
right now so all the guys number three
number four number five number six
they're all going to train just like
they did in 2016. they're going to train
all their energy on the number two guy
they're going to try to take him out so
that they have a chance to shoot at the
king because they know if you shoot at
the king you best not miss so they're
not going to go after Trump right away
there's no political Advantage for them
to do it they might they might throw a
few volleys just to save face but the
real guns are going to be trained on
Rhonda Santa so they've got to shake
something up
running as the new and improved version
of trump ain't working what is the
solution going to be I don't know I
don't work for the DeSantis campaign but
it's got to be something man if if the
fake ramaswami can do it and he can jump
way up in the polls surely the very
popular governor of Florida can do it
as well there's another I'm like singing
vivek's praises today not just because
the guy's a pal of mine but I'm
genuinely very impressed by his campaign
here's another idea he threw this one
out a couple weeks ago it didn't totally
land so we just moved on to the
fundraising idea but but I think it's a
pretty good one he established a
scholarship for patriotism
it's our son origin's first birthday
today and in honor of that my wife a
poor vendai
are committing to fund a new scholarship
to Foster American national pride among
Young Americans it's going to be called
the American identity scholarship
it's gonna allow 10 students 10 high
school students across the country to
win a 25
000 scholarship making it one of the
largest Scholarships in the country
for submitting a compelling and concise
video explaining why it is they're proud
to be an American and most importantly
what it means to be an American that's
something that we don't talk about
enough ask young people across the
country today what does it mean to be an
American
you often get a blank stare in response
that's the vacuum at the heart of our
national Soul less than 16 percent of
gen Z says they're proud to be American
today
so so this is cool I like it it didn't
get as big a splash as I suspect Vivek
was hoping for in the campaign so it
doesn't matter whatever the guy just
moves on he says okay now we're gonna do
this fundraising thing that did make a
big splash and he just keeps chipping
away just keeps throwing spaghetti at
the wall he just keeps mixing metaphors
like I'm mixing them right now and it
and it's working very well now the the
question
that they poses in the scholarship is
the central theme of his campaign and
it's a really important one
it's what is American identity
and I I love that question and I think
it's really
perspicacious it's a really incisive
theme for the campaign
but what's the answer
what is the answer to that question
conservatives are going to reflexively
think they have the answer to say the
America is the Spirit of 76 and freedom
and maybe
maybe but that wasn't always
the way that America viewed herself
that that is in many ways a creation of
the post-world War II liberal consensus
that America is a classically liberal
Nation founded on enlightenment values
that's a kind of actually a relatively
recent understanding America viewed
herself very differently in 1620 America
viewed herself very differently in 1776
America viewed herself very differently
in the early 19th century and in the
later 19th century and even in the early
20th century and we're going to view
ourselves very differently now so the
the conservatives are gonna have to
focus in on this what is it is America
primarily racial
Erica's never really been America's been
at least ostensibly a white country for
a lot of its history but it was it
it never merely a white country I mean
the story has always been much more
complicated than that Carl Jung has a
really good essay on this about how the
existence in America of Native American
Indians and black slaves and then freed
black people
always colored pun intended the the
American understanding of race and
character and so I don't think it's
really that exactly is America what is
it is it just freedom and Enlightenment
values no one's even read John Locke
nobody nor should they frankly no is
America what is is America the right to
do whatever you want to like chop
yourself up and engage in all sorts of
weird behaviors
I don't think so what is America one
nation under God this be our motto and
God is our trust that's a pretty
traditional understanding of what
America is what does that mean in 2023
that's a question
that a lot of us have to ask now on this
racial point before we go want to get to
Tommy tupperville
now you know what I'm running out of
time so that's going to be my tease it's
going to be my tease okay Tommy
tupperville though he's in trouble
because he is referring to White
nationalism and he's not condemning
white nationalism in the military or
something like that I think tuberville
has a perfect answer to it
but I'm going to leave you on that
Cliffhanger you're just gonna have to
wait until tomorrow now you got to tune
back in sorry folks let's walk Wednesday
we got stuff to get to on the member
block the rest of the show continues now
you don't want to miss it become a
member use code Knowles Canada Wes a
check out for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
foreign